hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and this is another special
episode of mindscape we're having enough
special episodes that you might begin to
think that every episode of mindscape is
special and you might be right about
that but this one is a departure I've
always wanted to get into not only sort
of academic kind of things but also the
realm of ideas out there in the real
world involving things like music which
we've already talked about movies and
also food and drink so I always thought
it'd be fun to have an episode of
mindscape devoted to the idea of wine
now wine obviously is a huge topic there
are many many things you could talk
about but ideally we'd be able to sort
of start at the beginning
give useful information to people who
knew nothing about wine or even you know
had had some and hated it but also give
some useful insight to people who are
experts in connoisseurs I think that we
have achieved that this is a very fun
episode happily I happen to know Matthew
Lucci who is today's guest he is the
sommelier at Malisse restaurant here in
Los Angeles for those of you who are not
locals melis is to michelin-starred
restaurant probably the most
sophisticated traditional fine-dining
white tablecloths French American
cuisine restaurant that you can find
here in Los Angeles there's really not
that much competition in fact so
Matthew's job is both to curate the wine
list at Malisse and then to serve the
wine in the restaurant so you know he's
a very influential person in the
Southern California wine world as you'll
see is added quite a young age he's also
very approachable very knowledgeable and
very much of the opinion that everyone
should enjoy wine in their own way so
when I asked him to be on the podcast he
was very enthusiastic and he said of
course I have to bring wine so yes we
will actually be tasting wine in real
time here on this episode of mindscape
and because we did that I thought it
would be fun to do another experiment
and bring in a third person for the
podcast my lovely wife Jennifer will let
- as a science writer and who I know
from drinking wine with her is much
better at tasting wine than I am she is
one of these super tasters who is
especially sensitive to COO sephorus
ness and bitterness and so forth so we
have some overlap in our tastes but it's
a little bit different so that's a new
perspective
and of course she's also written
articles about the science of taste and
smell and climate change and how it's
affecting wine and so forth so we we
have a lot of fun we start at the
beginning we taste both California wines
and French wines and we compare them and
we go from everything like what you
should serve with truffles to what you
should serve with cheeseburgers and I
think that it's a it's an eye-opening
experience Matthew has some he has
opinions which is good that's what you
wanted a podcast guest his opinions are
not the same as everybody else's which
is also very good so you're gonna learn
something you're gonna have fun I
recommend if possible that you have this
podcast on you know at home with some
wine in front of you if you could if
you're in the car listening then that's
also fine but be sure to you know
remember some of the things we say bring
them back home because this is
definitely one of the more educational
and useful episodes that we have here on
mindscape
so let's go
[Music]
that things that see welcome the blind
skate podcast thank you so much Sean
honor this is gonna be an unusual
episode of mine scape for a variety
reasons one because just the topic is a
little bit different you know I say
there's no such thing as what we talk
about but we often do a lot of science
and philosophy and things there will be
science and philosophy but mostly we're
talking about wine included in a kind of
aesthetic experience that we don't often
get to hear so that's great second
reason why it's different is we're gonna
be tasting wine
sadly the audience is not gonna be
tasting wine along with us I think
probably half the audience listens in
the car so they definitely shouldn't be
but not recommended not recommended but
yeah look if they're doing that at home
I will list the wines on the website and
they can buy and taste along with us
highly recommended third reason is
because we have a special guest Jennifer
Willett famous science writers say hi
Jennifer
hello everybody Jennifer is also as many
listeners will know my spouse and we
brought her here to give us a little bit
of an extra opinion about the wines that
we're tasting famously her palate is
much more refined and sensitive than
mine so don't listen to what I say but
listen to what she says
of course I think I hope that you know
part of our lesson will be that
everyone's palate is different so
that'll be good anyway Matthew thanks so
much for coming it's it's tell us a
little bit about who you are how you got
here like what's it mean to be a
sommelier well okay so a sommelier is
one that looks after and serves wine in
a restaurant that's how I would define
it there's a lot of definitions to it
but I think the restaurant aspect of it
is crucial I got into it young I
definitely had three year head start as
far as I'm the legally the real side of
it yeah just picturing local Californian
from central California Mariposa
California right I said Yosemite
National Park yeah I got a head start
just to make sure I could do all the
testing as soon as possible you know
very good cheating ahead of time yes
and so I mean wine is a specific thing
like why were you drinking wine rather
than the cheap beer that most kids that
age would be drinking
well I've just always been interested in
and fascinated by things with a lot of
variables and understanding why things
work and always been into music also so
kind of an artistic side and it sort of
instantly clicked with me that wine
seemed to be the most artistic way to go
about drinking essentially and you know
I like I said from California the most
of my friends were older than I am and
my early mentors were into California
wine and that's where I started and I
was kind of in the formative years while
working in a restaurant and not
disliking it a lot of people are working
in restaurants is a you know while doing
something else especially in Los Angeles
and I was like this isn't bad it's a
fairly easy way to make salt amount of
money and how do I just deal with wine
like how do I just isolate that and I
went to my lease on the total win with
my best friend and we just had our minds
absolutely blown he got super into the
culinary world
you know bought the Eleniak cookbook and
the French Laundry cookbook you know
spend eight hours making one course food
just to do it yeah and then I forked off
and was like okay how do I be a
sommelier and specifically be really
cool to be the sommelier here and that
works yeah actually had that happen and
so yeah I did the testing the first two
levels of the Court of Master Sommeliers
as its called
when I was 22 and went to Mele so over
the course of a couple years trying to
get hired and I was obviously young and
that point didn't have any fine-dining
experience and it's one of those things
like it's one of those things where you
know how do you get experience without
having experience yeah
like okay how do I break in well go
somewhere a bunch of times and bug them
until they say yes you can work one day
a week and then that becomes 2 and then
that becomes your in assistance and then
someone leaves and you're the wine
director so I mean for the people I
think that we have an audience where
some people are gonna be wine experts
and some will never have tasted let's
say good wine wine at all what is it
that makes wine wine
what's it what is it that makes it so
special what differentiates it from on
the one hand you know gin or scotch but
also for that matter apple juice or Diet
Coke mm-hmm well you know certainly gin
and scotch reflect a place I don't think
they do it to the level that wine does I
really think that there's an intrinsic
locality specificity of locality to wine
as in like this vineyard not going
across the street to the next vineyard
like hyper hyper sumed in combined with
that it's from a vintage it's from one
year and it changes over time you know
some liqueurs do but not in the same way
that wine does that there's a lifespan
and a trajectory to it that is
fascinating and again with so many
variables that go into it there's a lot
of BS that goes into it unfortunately
and it is also unfortunately can be
easily pretentious topic and I really
don't like that and wine is fascinating
and wine is cool and some people make it
not that way is there any way to put
that in the in the in terms of the
actual product I mean there's something
complicated about lying I mean that in
the good way not in the bad way yeah
there's something about wine that lends
itself to endless variety in a way that
bourbon does not yeah well so without
being a biologist but from you know what
I do understand about the way wine works
so the the grapes that make up wine are
called vidis vinifera that is everything
that you produce wine from Forks off of
that so Pinot Noir Chardonnay Merlot
Syrah Nebbiolo Tokai free Liana or
whatever it is it's all vit Aspen ephra
it's a type of grape yes and
their berries are about a third of this
size I want to say of like table grapes
at concord grapes they're much harsher
if you just eat one like in a vineyard I
mean especially red I mean there's the
if you don't understand tannin you ever
get a chance to go walk around a
vineyard coastal harvest you will
understand it better
so it mutate s-- easily and splits off
into you know different not forms but
like Pinot Noir Pinot Gris those are
linked you know the so beyond Blanc and
Cabernet Franc are the mother and father
respectively of Cabernet Sauvignon they
were crossed that's why it has its name
so there's a level of complexity from
the biology standpoint as I understand
it that is I don't know unique to wine
it seems to be like spread out wider
with wine so it's re does the basic
facts that grapes come in more varieties
than wheat or barley do is an important
part of it ah I can't just be one form
of wheat I don't want to say that okay
sure but yeah someone in the comments is
gonna destroy me but you know I I think
that part of it when you're dealing okay
so in either hemisphere basically the
the band of 30 degrees in 50 degrees is
the you know the Goldilocks zone as it
were of where you can successfully ripen
Venice vinifera to have sugar levels
compatible with fermentation you know
below 30 they're just getting baked
above 50 although this is changing above
50 they're struggling to have the
physiological ripeness for the yeast to
ferment and they're all there's nowhere
that makes wine that isn't pretty it
really is like any wine region you want
to go even if you're not into it like
just go and eat there and hang out there
I think that one of the things that gets
in the way of people who are not wine
experts is that it is complicated right
I mean this is the benefit this is the
wonderful thing but it's also
intimidating yeah so I mean besides red
and white
what are the basic ways in which we
should classify different wines in our
heads like you know high alcohol of
alcohol is an obvious one full-bodied
less full body yeah what else is going
on well um so I do think about this in a
binary way and I think it's helpful for
understanding especially if you're
beginning so let's take let's take red
just just to for now you mentioned
alcohol content that definitely is a
factor that's really more of a factor of
climate and winemaker decision which
we'll get into but with red wine the way
I look at it the first fork in the road
is is it thin-skinned or is it
thick-skinned okay
so thin-skinned varietals are Pinot Noir
Gamay Grenache Sangiovese Tempranillo
and Nebbiolo there's no main ones
there's other like funky ones but those
are the six main ones and then
everything else is thick-skinned so
Cabernet Sauvignon Merlot Petit Verdot
Syrah this is strictly a matter of what
grape varietal it is yes yeah if you
know the varietal then you know was
thicker thinner yes
kourosh is the funky one that people
don't really like think is thin-skinned
but it depending on where it's from it
can like kind of seemingly wear both
hats but anyway so thin-skinned
thick-skinned and habits that transfer
form into a feature of the wine that
you're drinking thin skinned makes a
lighter wine essentially thick skin will
make a heavier wine there's a another
one of the weird thin skinned grapes is
Nebbiolo that's the only one where you
it's basically like I call it's like
Pinot Noir wrapped in fine grit
sandpaper it's it's it's tannic but
light usually the thick-skinned grapes
are gonna have more tannin structure but
Nebbiolo is this funky one amazing one
but that's kind of outlier so
thin-skinned thick-skinned and then the
other really major thing to look at is
Earth verse fruit and that is a function
of where it's from
and the wine world is roughly divided
into
not quite halves but two parts the old
world in the new world basically the old
worlds Europe the new world is
everywhere that's not Europe a euro
centric choice of language but that's
okay yeah yeah and blanket statement
wines from the old world are grown in a
cooler climates cleanse wines from the
new world are grown in a warmer climate
so they tend to be riper and the riper
grapes are getting the more fruit driven
they tend to be if the grapes aren't
getting as ripe they tend to reflect
more of the surroundings of the vineyard
the soil type and you're tasting more of
the earth flavors that's a
generalization there's exceptions to
like anything we could talk about here
somewhere but basically old world new
world that's how it shakes out so
those major the matrixes of is it light
or heavy function of the thickness of
the skin is it more fruit driven or more
earth driven within that you have the
variables of what the alcohol content
will be and the other thing that plays
into that or that's a function of all of
that is acidity verse tannin so again
the binary way I described this is acid
makes your mouth water tan and dries
your mouth out that's what a nice I like
that um you know over steep a tea bag
and taste it that's tan yes just over
steep your tea yeah
whereas lemon juice is that is acid
makes your mouth water yeah yeah now in
the context of wine acid III hesitate to
call wines acidic because it doesn't
sound great but like acid driven bright
racy high toned those kind of
descriptors are tend to be describing
wines that have a higher level of
acidity which makes them brighter makes
them more refreshing if you will would a
chemist go along with this would they
say that what you are calling an acidic
wine actually is more acidic versus
basic and then yeah is the pH level you
measure so is it objectively yeah yeah
pH I mean like a like a low pH wine is
if it's three even like that's that's
acid driven and then you're going up so
like four that's that's a high for you
I'm or tannic then no not necessarily
because they're different so on and they
come together so they work together so
the tannin level there's a way to really
measure it from a chemistry standpoint
like there is with pH but like well as
we get into these wines we can sort of
like talk about how they intermingle but
basically acid and tannin that you kind
of taste them one on top of each other
and if you could magically take away the
acid from a wine you would notice how
much less spine it has like it's called
structure what acid and tannin imparts
into wine but but they're two separate
sort of properties that kind of do
opposite things by like so the Tea Act
removes the moisture from your from your
mouth and the acid adds it but in
principle you could have a line that was
both very tannic and very acidic yes
again Nebbiolo that's it Nebbiolo is
raising its hands somewhere going that's
me
so we've had four things to keep in mind
yeah light versus heavy yeah earthy
versus fruity level of acidity leaven
level of tannic miss adjust level of
tannin look at those okay um and that's
red grapes white you get to just take
out tannin because so the juice of all
grapes is clear the only thing that
makes red wine red is contact with the
skins now there is what's called orange
wine which is white wine made like a red
wine that's gaining in popularity a lot
of like funky bars and stuff with poor
language they're fun for food pairing
you see a lot of them in like Croatia
and is you're a part of Europe but white
you still have the acid you don't have
the tannin you still have body although
it sort of manifests differently you
know light white grapes sodium Blanc
this uh all this is depending on how
it's made to and you can make a
Sauvignon Blanc into a really rich like
oaky style of wine or you can not so
just this grape varietal make up things
like moose g'day vermin Tino Sophia
Blanc those are light zippy bright zesty
white wines marcin ruse on those are big
oily fat
or punching your styles of white wine
via a really oily also really floral so
white it kind of has a whole other you
need a different way of thinking about
in describing white wine Chardonnay is
one of my favorite topics because it's
one of the most misunderstood things
ever and it this dis applies to all wine
like have this conversation at the
restaurant you know nightly you know oh
other things you like things you don't
like I do not want Chardonnay is it
because you don't like quote oaky
buttery wines yes okay I always equate
this to Good Will Hunting it's not your
fault it's not your fault
that's not your fault people have been
exposed to a lot of bad Jordan yeah
right it's not it's not Chardonnay
people exposed to a lot of bad [ __ ] Lee
I mean I had a lot of bad white Shipley
and in college and it's it's turned me
off white wine for a very long yeah well
a lot of that the California Shipley as
always called that is not cheb Lee that
is that is not the from the appellation
origin control II in the north
northeastern part of France it's not far
from Champaign Shibley is a place just
like champagne is a place and I dare you
you see old bottles of California wine
that's to california Sauternes
california burgundy california bleah
you'll before that AO seas were formed
in 1936 and it became you can't you
can't do that but you know we have this
beautiful lovely wine in front of us and
now we have a little bit of a capability
for understanding yeah but i know
because we do have a heterogeneous
audience let's I want I want some
take-home messages right away you know
what should someone do if they're not a
wine expert and they kind of want to be
more like they they want to investigate
you know what are the steps they should
take in a wine store or restaurant or
whatever to sort of get the basics and
find something they like I would say
find a local wine shop get a couple
friends and be honest and going on a few
bottles that have their opposite styles
and start down and what it is you do or
do not like so buy one shop you mean not
Superboy I mean not supermarket yeah not
to you know a place where they know and
like one yes see you know the money will
almost always go farther you will have a
staff that's specifically trained to
talk about and sell wine and also
usually love wine my early helpful
and so get something like buddy get
something full buddy get something
earthy exactly yeah and split them up
get what you might think maybe it might
be too many glasses at the house but you
never have enough never I do yeah and
just start learning and pay attention to
it which you know I don't mean that to
sound like sharp but you know think
about what it is that you're tasting and
think about how you would try to
articulate it and try to articulate it
don't just if you don't know what to say
that's fine but make notes go back to
that wine shop hey this is this is what
I thought what do you think where do we
go now I I didn't like that wine that
really dried all the took all the saliva
out of my mouth mouth what does that
mean that that Chardonnay that I thought
was gonna be oaky and buttery it was
like razor blades like what happened
they're like what you know just be
honest be inquisitive and I really can't
stress enough like do it in a group do
it with least you know one other person
but just to bounce off each other and
you know people are gonna pick out
things that you wouldn't notice and vice
versa and you know the rising tides
right so it's possible to do okay at the
$20 bottle level yes absolutely I'd say
I'm glad you brought that up because I
think there is somewhat of a break there
just as far as what it it's hard to do
well at the time on do yeah you know the
exception if you're in Europe and you
ask for the table wine it'll be you know
sometimes like six euros for a carafe
and it'll be awesome
sometimes but your chances of it being
awesome are way higher there than they
are here you're dealing with the tariffs
and all that stuff but 20 like you got
to be able to spend 20 bucks on a bottle
of wine and it's five drinks like would
you complain at a bar if you were paying
that for cockpit like you know it's 20
bucks is where you reasonably should
start and you yeah there is no
quality/price ratio in the wine world
there are a lot of ways to waste money
i'm really fortunate to work where I do
have got to taste a lot of crazy wines
a lot of them that are really expensive
are absolutely worth it if you could
afford them and not feel it and a lot of
them I like just a waste of money
so I mean just for the people who might
never actually experience themselves it
is there a difference between a thousand
dollar bottle of wine in a ten thousand
dollar bottle of wine
it depends what they are but there can
be oh yes yeah absolutely I mean this
seems I think to a lot of people for
whom a $50 bottle of wine is expensive
totally yeah that one is a thousand
dollar but it is exactly so but the idea
might very well be that at some point
there's a point of diminishing returns
oh no you're paying for micro percentage
increase at that point and you're just
paying for what it is I mean is what it
is like I mean literally I mean if you
know the most famous winery in the world
that tends to basically most of the most
expensive bottles of wine sold the
domaine de la romanée-conti
in Burgundy they're insanely good yes re
they are I think you as a like physics
analogy you sort of land it's kind of
like the Large Hadron Collider okay very
expensive is it is it worth literally a
million times what some what you can do
for a thousand dollars
mmm no but if you don't spend the
billions of dollars you get nothing do
you find a Higgs boat right yeah you
don't you don't find a thousand that the
Higgs boson you find nothing yeah yeah
so if you want to play that at that
level then that's what yeah and no DRC
is not whatever percentage it is better
than whatever you want to compare it to
but there's only one DRC right and
there's a lot of things in the middle of
that price range and things that are
equal to the kinds of money you can
spend on those kind of wines that are
one-dimensional and you're tasting the
investors and the winemakers ego you're
not tasting this like historically
consistent place that is just like
renowned for a reason so and in
everywhere across that spectrum that
exists I mean more and more and more my
favorite wines are like I call them the
beautiful Bay
from the great producers you know in
places like Burgundy where there's a
classification system of the vineyards
where you have vineyards that are
classified as regional like it's from
Burgundy somewhere or then it's from a
specific little village in Burgundy and
then or it's from a specific vineyard in
Burgundy and then it's from a really
really good vineyard in Burgundy the
four different levels what's called
Bourgogne the most simple of them from
the great winemakers is a fraction of
the price of the expensive stuff but
you're still getting that expertise in a
simple wine and that's that's the golden
place to be now some of those can be 50
60 bucks to start but you're drinking 50
$60 wine from people who are making six
seven eight nine $100 bottle of wine you
know speaking of drinking wine no you
decide wine four different bottles of
wine here and you have a theory I mean
there's a there's a system for why
there's four there's a reason yeah only
reads a lot of reason so they're all red
red good that's because I said yes yes
requested red that's fine no no episode
two will do all white so yeah I wanted
to talk about the thin skin thick skin
thing that I talked about and then also
the old world first the new world so the
only way to do that successfully is to
have four wines so excellent math skills
yeah from a physicist everyone so yeah I
have a Sonoma Coast Pinot Noir versus a
red burgundy so I've talked about buried
a couple times but without explaining
what that is so that is a region in the
central eastern part of France not far
from the Swiss border that makes Pinot
Noir and Chardonnay a couple other
grapes that grow aligote a and Gamay but
for the most part pinot noir and
chardonnay and that's it and pretty much
the greatest examples of them that is
changing there is competition that is
mounting all the time but the
competition is still bounced off
Burgundy it's just yeah it's the
reference but it's this and it's the
standard yeah it is okay so the
California Pinot Noir
yes Burgundy also Pinot Noir yes yeah if
it's red and it's from Burgundy its
Pinot Noir
No
blending everything here is just one
varietal there's no blends the
California Pinot Noir is made by a
winery named Cobb and he's in the Sonoma
Coast so the Sonoma Coast is this big
place it's like saying oh where do you
live LA County okay it's kind of helpful
but it could be a lot of things so
Sonoma Coast but specifically the
vineyards that Ross Cobb is working with
are in this little undefined sub region
of the Sonoma Coast that they're working
on getting passed through as an official
sub region called freestone Occidental
that's just a few miles inland from the
ocean meaning that the grapes are socked
in a marine layer a lot of time and also
in these coastal regions you have really
wide what are called diurnal shifts so
that's the difference between the
hottest time of the day and the coolest
time of the night and pretty much
categorically across the wine world
grapes want that they want to be
stressed they want to be bouncing around
temperature wise but Pinot Noir
specifically is kind of a nightmare
it's really finicky hard to grow grapes
requires just perfect perfect conditions
to not be either shrill if it's under
ripe or flabby and sort of no longer a
silky pretty sexy textured wine if it's
getting to right so this specific little
pocket of the Sonoma Coast is great for
it
Ross has a really condemned touch very
hands-off winemakers I call him and any
great winemaker I don't want to taste
what you can do with a wine I want to
taste the white wine right so I want to
actually taste this one yeah let me just
just so this look forward a little bit
so that our audience knows where we're
going these two the first ones are Pinos
old the new world and the next two are
second to our Syrah
so again California and France that'll
be the thicker skin yeah acceptability
yeah full-bodied especially the
California iteration the French Syrah
really is not much heavier than the red
bergen he's going to be but I would do
that on purpose there's a couple kind of
almost backwards things in this flight
that I always like to illustrate that
you know these
wide brushstrokes are not always
accurate so or there are exceptions to
them I should say so - Pinot Noirs both
from the 2015 vintage and then to
surahs' both from the 2010 vintage 15 in
California you know coming out of
drought a string of drought vintages
warm but not really warm not to the
level of 1314 and then in in France 15
is really really widely acclaimed it's a
little bit of a riper rounder vintage
2015 2015 yeah yeah but the yields are
down as they've been in Burgundy for the
past basically ten vintages in a row
which we'll get into later while that's
happening but basically the California
Pinot Noir which typically you again
broad-stroke California versus France
you're going to get a more fruit driven
heavier style of wine from a warmer
climate and then the European wines
typically are more earth driven and more
rustic and here they're kind of
backwards neither of them is necessarily
rustic but the burgundy is a little bit
more svelte and kind of slick due to the
warmer vintage and different winemaking
styles between them but both master
master winemakers the burgundy is from a
producer named Bruno Claire from a
specific little village in Burgundy
called Sava Neela bone and then one
vineyard called la dominoed and Domino
was planted in 1908 so the oldest vines
in this vineyard date back to then and
basically his vines get older they
produce less juice so the juice they do
produce is more concentrated tends to
give you a more complex wine tends to
give you more age worthy wine it's
literally the same vines like you take a
snip from a vine and replant you can do
that these I mean there's a point where
some of them stop producing altogether
so there's always less and less and less
and less of the old vines and they're
replanting other parts of the vineyard
so not every vine and this is from 1908
that's the arrow time at work I didn't
there it is we think of individual
animals as having a life span but you
don't really think of plants yeah yeah
give up at some point anyway yeah
taste a new world okay good so this is
the California Pinot Noir calm rice
Spivak vineyard Sonoma Coast Pinot Noir
and what we looking for when we're
tasting this so what I do is I always
smell first and it first it sounds
obvious but a lot of people don't a lot
of him just go into the glass and just
go right in but you know obviously our
sense of taste and sense of smell are
linked and part of especially you're
dealing with Pinot Noir I mean it's just
it is like Lacey pretty feminine
understated floral exactly I want to sum
all of that and this wine smells
gorgeous and more right now yes yeah
that you know and this I always get like
kind of like pomegranate like lavender
again that racy high tone bright acidity
that you'll see on the end you feel it
in your tongue you feel it everywhere
really but the way that the finish like
sings and keeps going that is why you
need wine that has a fair amount of
acidity in it if you if you don't have
that you just don't get the same level
of kind of width and breadth and depth
yeah I'm actually very surprised this is
a 2015 Shawn knows that I don't like
younger wines cuz I don't like super
super fruity wines and I feel it's the
acidity here that makes this so
pleasurable and so drinkable it actually
allows those those lighter floral notes
to come out and it kind of softens the
fruit component a little bit yeah yeah I
mean you just have a really really
integrated wine and for it to be
integrated this well this young this
wine isn't even technically released yet
this producers really adamant about
holding the wines back two three four
years longer than most wineries do just
because he wants them to hit when
they're killing it not that this isn't
but but it's gonna age in a couple years
it's gonna be perfect I it'll be better
I mean this is a I would say 30 year
wine easily usually and the other thing
here that I love is the salinity
and that's another thing there's a
common thread through the wines that I
love is here it's coming from like I
said that marine layer you know imagine
it you got you're eating a perfect dish
at a great restaurant just cuz nothing
tastes salty doesn't mean that there's
not salt in it if you could take it out
and you notice it's gone so I think of
line musically and and bass middle
treble on an equalizer so acidity is
kind of likens to the treble if
listening to a record and you turn all
the treble off you can't hear it there's
no definition there the precision is
gone about that bass no treble is not it
was a great example of a perfect
high-end you know in a great record when
you say something like pomegranate so I
would not have said that but when you
say it I can sort of recognize it after
the fancy what happens do you think that
right so there's a psychology experiment
going on also but do you think that
there are literally molecules that would
be in a pomegranate that are also in yes
there are yeah when we get to the Syrah
we'll talk about rotund done so that's
the thing that makes black pepper black
pepper huh Syrah if it doesn't smell
like black pepper got messed up
somewhere and presumably there's
advanced scientific research going on
trying to deconstruct a wine like this
and try to make it try to make us
understand why it tastes / recreated in
a petri dish yes yes but we can't I mean
we're not successful we can make an
impossible burger but we cannot make
fake wine yet it's common so it's coming
I mean as you know I mean it's atoms
yeah there's nothing else as much as I
am an yeah me and friends like talked
about this a lot over a lot of bottles
of wine and the moral conundrums of a
sommelier yeah I mean imagine you could
tune whatever wine you wanted that would
be kind of yeah chemistry is very very
complicated but there is in fact a lot
of ongoing research correct yeah I see
Davis for example but in other places
around the world are very much looking
at the chemical composition of these for
just that reason the better you
understand the chemical components on
what's going on the chemistry not just
you know in space but into overtime the
more you can tailor the flavor profiles
to your liking
yeah well in in the
or you'll learn about if we're if we're
not making wine in a petri dish the more
you can you could better farm
I mean wine is forming / gardening
however you want to look at it but
somewhere in the middle of those things
you know everything you're doing has an
impact it's all you know prior cause is
everything it's all happening in a
vineyard and at the end of the day you
can only make great wine from great
grapes you can go the other way you know
you can you can mess it up but you can't
just like take subpar lazily farmed kind
of lifeless grapes and turn them into a
complex head-spinning beverage it just
doesn't work that way so there's a lot
of reasons why that happens there are
variables that we do know about you know
like vine age is a big one I mentioned
that with the Burgundy with the old
vines they make less juice but they tend
to just have a wine that's a little bit
more concentrated and and I look at the
structure of a wine again like I
mentioned which is acid and tannin and
then vine age plays into that is like
the charging of the batteries of the
wine like how long how long will the
charge last essentially and you mean
over years not over since you opened the
bottle and start a drink what both we
talked about that - I'm more talking
about in the bottle but good wine can
take way more oxygen than people realize
I mean let might like I have a couple
litmus tests for how much I really like
a wine and one of them is how is it on
day three mmm some wine some styles of
wine are absolutely better on day three
and in the in pairings at the restaurant
all open wines on my way out the door
for the next night kind of thing and
summer vinegar after day three yeah
exactly that's that has to do with
structure and then also the aging of the
wine in the bottle you know did wine
that last 40 50 60 70 a hundred years
you know there has to be if we're
talking Reds like there's some level of
tannin in there there's some level of
acidity the grapes have to have
structure which I equate to our skeleton
I mean there's a reason we can sit in
these chairs and walk around and
you know that that is the equivalent of
that in in wine is the intermingling of
acid and what's the oldest one you've
ever had well I have two answers to that
one of them is Madeira
says fortify wine from the tropical it's
a cheating is it it can't go bad
from late seventeen hundreds I forget to
Vantage on it but always but late what
century yeah so drove a lot of that old
America like the billionaire's vinegar
with Thomas Jefferson's wine correct
yeah the fake wine the fake got a couple
of those too that's the whole thing okay
but none fortified not fortified late
1800 vintages Bordeaux like like Oh
prion from like 1898 Lafitte they
holding up yeah you've got like 20
minutes at most meat on tasting like two
out like two ounces if I'm lucky an
ounce here and there and that dries out
really quick in the glass but so with it
sorry but that's an important lesson
right a lot of people think the older
the wine is the more you have to decant
it and let it air out and that there's a
point of diminishing returns there
definitely so yeah oxygen helps till it
hurts right all the way across the
spectrum so anyway if you have a what
are called good or great vintages and I
dislike the way of describing them which
we can talk about later because you have
to say what that's for
go to our bad for what there's quote
poor vintages when it come out that are
better to drink young and then quote
great vintages usually don't drink well
young because they're very primary and
they're meant to go the distance like
manner desert bunny style down the road
that's when they're meant to be drink
but in those ripe quote-unquote great
vintages those wines take longer to
unpack so if you're going to open them
young detaining them as helpful I'd you
can't more white wine than I do read at
this point that's another thing I think
lot of people misunderstand white can
handle way more oxygen than most people
give it and I am a bigger fan at this
point just letting red wine slow slow ox
as they call it like slowly come up in
the glass
rather than trying to like fast-forward
it so we enjoy how it changes over the
glass the meal yeah exactly
and part of that is I'm like pretty OCD
about not crossing pores as I call it so
especially if you're dealing with an
older wine you know you pour two to
three ounces never more than that take
know you don't you know you never want
six ounces of wine in a glass if you can
unless you're just ordering wine by the
glass so it dip it is just not helpful
you get less out of it in the long run
that's interesting because of course you
know America there's kind of like we
want to get our money's worth
sure and this is a very different kind
of aesthetic where you know to get your
money's worth means you want the wine to
be as good as possible yeah and that's
not a quantity question yeah basically I
I want you know roughly 25 ounces of
wine and a 750 milliliter bottle to turn
into as many wines as I can possibly let
it turn into so if I'm dealing with this
that happens more usually with older
wines but if I'm pouring two people two
ounces they get 10 wines if you're
playing along and also how the empty
glass smells is a beautiful thing yeah
and that actually is helpful with young
wine if if something's had maybe like
too much oak put on it or there's a
little bit too much treatment that's
oftentimes what you smell in the glass I
call it the finish of the nose so people
talk about the palate and the finish of
the palate and just the nose but it's
not technically the finish of the nose
but I think of it that way like what are
the remnants all about okay so we've
enjoyed this yeah with 2015 California
Pinot it was I mean this is a high-level
one relatively speaking but it this is a
more fruity than earthy because it is
new more driven than Earth and more it's
very acidic bright you know light on the
palate and now we're moving to the old
world yes to the Bruno Claire and I
won't lead the witness I'll have you
tasted no okay we're gonna taste it and
who knows what could happen anything
really mine scape the wine edition it's
very different half thousand miles well
but that's it it's more in the in the
way they handled the acidity I think
because here the acidity is very front
and center and
very very pronounced and here it's more
blended and smooth and a little more
gentle BAM I yep yep that's that's a
relatively warm vintage in a place that
doesn't have a ton of them and
definitely to do with the factory doing
with an old vineyard so this is the one
where the actual vines are from 1908
partisan yeah block I forget exactly
like what the split is but they're being
you know there's 1908 planning there's
plantings in the fifties
I mean there's no like usually if vines
are in this part of the world if they're
under 20 years old they're not even they
like sell it off is this a long that
will age more than the first one
hard to not see yes although I don't
wanna say anything against the first one
no I joined what is a lovely wine is
that they're both 2015 and I would have
and if I was did not know would think
that the second was older like the first
one tastes like an excellent 2015 yes I
want a solder right right out of it yeah
absolutely I would drink this you know
it's wonderful but there's just
something a little extra the edge is off
I guess yeah that's a good way to put it
on yeah and you know they're both so you
can sort of put wine into three
timelines of like primary secondary
tertiary as far as their lifespans go
and let's sleep roughly say let's take
the Brunel Clare like I say primary is
probably the first you know they say in
the first 10 years of Burgundy you taste
the winemaker and then after that you
start to taste the terroir the t-word
the infamous so would say 10 to 15 years
is primary maybe 15 to 25 is secondary
and then once you're past 25 or 30
you're into tertiary and you're shedding
fruit flavors as you go in exchanging
them for you know earthy soil did you
live there smiley yeah in like leather
in like like oh like I was even old
library like I think it's like the musty
easiest way to oh you're speaking yeah
tell you I love these older leathery
smoky wine oh it's amazing and and it's
okay so to circle back on you know what
makes wine what's different about it the
time capsule of it I mean yeah you know
when you're drinking whatever vintage it
is like think about what's going on in
the world that's how its mind-blowing
and just cool that you can do these
parallels to draw and it's a whole
nother conversation piece and it doesn't
need to be all like I'm not just I'm not
right I'm not alienating young wines
like just those notes can be there in
the young life
yeah like this is from when we fill in
the blank or when this happened or do
you remember that time went you know
this is that that's definitely a factor
in wine did so the first seems
noticeably more acidic to me they
neither one of them seems especially
tannic yeah so these thank you for for
saying that so these are tannic pinot
noir doesn't it isn't a tannic grape if
you had a Pinot Noir that was tannic it
would be from oak tannins so oak new oak
barrels can impart their own tannins
which are different than grape tannins
and these wines are both made from
winemakers that don't do that which i
think is but Pinot Noir doesn't really
want to be made that way typically so
wine is generally aged in oak but some
of its new some of its old yes there's I
mean you can use cement you can use
stainless and then in oak there's french
american Slovenian Hungarian but yeah
everything on the table is French when
we get to the Cobo tea they use barrels
that are about three times the size of
the barrels that every other wine here
is using which are 225 litre if you just
think of a wine barrel the first thing
that comes to your mind that's 225
liters and the bigger you go the less
surface yep contact with the line so the
less is imparted and on both both of
these are actually pretty similar
they're about a third new oak each the
Bruno Claire might be 20% and then the
rest of the oak that's being used has
already been used one other time so it's
not like old old oak okay some of these
sellers man in France like data like
yeah that's you know 20 30 year old
barrel like they have Cooper's am
just to because they do not want new
barrels and you walk into these places
and you're like oh that's why no Claire
smells away it does I'm aware smelling
it you're like oh yeah the mold on the
walls is from every fermentation that's
happened in here yeah yeah alright let's
move on to our Syrah okay
so the next wine is from favio wines so
this is a husband-and-wife team to look
really really acclaimed wine makers in
California Annie favia is the
viticulture list so she's doing all the
work in the vineyard she's married to
Andy Ericson who's the winemaker and if
you combined their resumes it's
basically every top culty hard to get
Cabernet Sauvignon predominately out of
the Napa Valley and they have friends
that own this vineyard in Amador County
not far from where I grew up and they
make it in Napa and this is a really
good example of a fairly full throttle
fuller bodied style of California Sarada
it doesn't go over the top it's you know
we've jumped up in an alcohol content
here the first two wines were about 1313
five now we're at fourteen eight and
we're in thick-skinned varietal with
Syrah it's like a completely different
beverage really it really is yeah very
even I would be able to say oh yes this
is a California why right away but see
still there's lift still there's
persistence there's energy it doesn't
just go away and that is really the
structure that's what I want in wine it
keeps you coming back to the glass it
makes it infinitely easier to pair with
food wine doesn't have acidity food
pairings become difficult weird it's not
possible at a high level right I'm
getting a very strong like all of you
know they don't yeah prudish note here
okay yeah so I mean I mean think what it
is
think of a ripeness level of you know
we're dealing with riper fruit here and
all of you see that in Syrah often I
don't know the name of that compound
Sean I'm sorry
I do I am it's not overpowering but it's
very noticeable prominent yeah it's
overpowering it's the most prominent
for me mm-hmm and I like I always like
saying I'll remember you said that when
we get to the GMA to cocoa tea which I
find all of into in a different way and
I would say a more integrated way but
even though this is a high alcohol wine
relatively speaking you don't get that
burdening that you get into sort of the
cheese it's still balanced it's balanced
and it's still young I mean you know
this is 2010 I don't know if I said that
both the Syrah or 2010 just ties in to
how wine ages but I explained it you
know the alcohol is never gonna change
everything else in the wine can shed and
change and evolve and congeal and
whatever but you always have this pillar
in the middle so sorry that's like
unless your bottle is not court
correctly or whatever the the literal
amount of alcohol in the bottle never
changes that's not a chemical reaction
yeah many other reactions 4.8% ethanol
that's there for the long haul and that
becomes if if the wines out of balance
that becomes more obvious though older
they get you see this a lot that was
really acclaimed vintage in the Napa
Valley 1997 the the wineries dealt with
huge yields from the vineyards larger
than they could physically handle so
they had to pick like half the fruit
start dealing with it while the other
half is in the vineyard getting too ripe
and then bringing the other half and it
got just Rockstar scores left and right
Parker's just dealing out 100 points
Coors and now most of them do not show
well and you put your nose in the glass
and it's like porty child prodigies yeah
so that never changes and then when you
have lower alcohol wines they're just
more seamless and if you're more
seamless when the wines you want to be
seamless all the way through right so
you you don't notice it in if there's a
young wine that's high alcohol it's
better young I just like categorically
disagree when I look at these like
drinking windows of some of these big
massive wines like oh Italy just 35
years I don't like it will like it will
physically be drinkable but I don't know
what it will taste like then if you if
you dig that just do
drink it but there I think better young
there so for our non expert listeners
like being the best wines in the world
like the classic Bordeaux's Burgundy's
and whatever what alcohol level have
they traditionally been at I say 13 is
is like a good Goldilocks basically if
you're below eleven and a half percent
you're the grapes aren't there's just
not enough energy there's not enough
food for the yeast to ferment there's a
sweet spot definitely now you see I
should say that this is for dry wines
and most wines produced in the world are
dry if you have dry meaning low sugar
yes yes and there's no what's called
residual sugar so leftover sugar from
the fermentation like you know there's
Rieslings from Germany in the Mosel that
are 7% that are delicious but their
sweetness there's also a city to balance
it out they're like deceptively not
sweet when you drink a lot of them but
so those are like outside of what I'm
talking about if you're fermenting a
wine to dryness it's basically got to be
like eleven eleven and a half or else
it's gonna just be razor blades and then
once you get over fourteen and a half
let's say that's where you're even into
fifteen depending on what the style of
the wine is that's where it starts to be
noticeable and I start to get off the
train there's a place in there's a
sub-region in Provence called band all
whose wines I love and they've just
overlooked and they're right on the
Mediterranean and back to the diurnal
shifts huge Township so it's a warm part
of France but then you're on the sea so
they come way down in temperature and
those wines can be fourteen five all day
and you'd never notice it there's just
the integration that they have but yeah
I'd say like like I said the two
Burgundy's we're drinking or thirteen
the lowest alcohol is gonna be the
fourth wine the domains GMA co-wrote E
which is twelve five but you look at
like old Bordeaux and even old the old
Napa cabs like from the golden era of
right when Apple was starting to blow up
late 60's to the mid 70s been late
these other 12% alcohol cavern ooze and
they stage incredibly wise yeah some of
my favorite wines and now those some of
those same producers a lot of them are
in different hands but you know they're
making 15 15 5 but there was a high it's
high yeah well I mean claiming that they
have wiggle room to they can lie about
it okay to a degree there can be like 16
and there was a thing not too long ago
for like big alcohol BOM wines like
Zinfandels and cabs from California
would be very high alcohol and probably
they're partly because the American
palate is not that sophisticated and
they like their booze yeah you know so
there's a lot of like geopolitical
things going on and why maybe that's not
the right descriptor but there's a lot
of outside factors with that and I think
so
critics you're a big part of this it's
just impossible to not talk about it and
you know basically when you see the
alcohol levels go up and the right like
let's take Napa like a really good
example of it like I just said you know
late 60s 70s or 12 12 5 in the 80s they
started irrigating so everything was dry
farmed before then and like in most of
Europe it's illegal to irrigate so the
irrigation if you're making wine yeah
yeah it's considered cheating or ya know
cheating and it raises the yield so
basically the lower the yield typically
the more concentrated the wine typically
the more complex the wine and therefore
in quotes better the line the higher the
yields the more dilute typically that
the flavors are gonna be so in the 80s
they start irrigating and then right
after that something called Falak sarah
hit Napa which hit the whole wine world
basically in Europe in the mid-1800s
wiped out the vineyards in Europe so
it's a disease yeah it's a little like
microscopic like pests it dehydrates the
roots and he's yeah this is interesting
so American rootstock is impervious to
it but it was introduced into France
from American it was brought over but
American it like traveled with the roots
and then but it's impervious to it so 99
percent of the vineyards in Europe are
planted on to American rootstock okay
and that happened in the mid 1800s
flocks were a hit it took them 5060
years to figure out how to fix it in
that time a lot of the vineyards got
poisoned that's actually part of why you
see a lot of organic and biodynamic
viticulture happening now is undoing
what happened then pretty yeah really
macro like farming stuff but so that
happened in Napa there's a specific kind
of root stock that was susceptible to it
that funny enough UC Davis like
recommended everyone use and then before
they knew that flocks were that loved it
sorry science is messy some yeah yeah
we're learning we're learning so you
have irrigation then philosophy so
basically a reset button happens and
then vineyards get replanted so now you
have young vines and going into the
early 90s into the mid 90s this is when
like the cult Cabernet thing happens
this is when scores are becoming more
and more of a thing spectator Robert
Parker all that and not that that didn't
exist before but it's really more into
the mainstream getting into the dot-com
boom so there's there's money coming
into this part of the world it wasn't
there before to that level and people
like wind at own winery and you have you
know the way a lot of these tastings
happen where they're doing the scores
that are tasting a hundred wines in a
row so the only things that pop and get
high scores are big high alcohol wines
just cuz physiologically that's what you
will go WOW to and it created this thing
that I I refer to correlate it to the
loudness wars which is something that
happened in the music industry really in
the same time which is interesting where
basically like just as humans were sort
of wired to think that louder is better
it is obvious it is yeah oh you want
your song to be the louder yes exactly
oh this song bang it up nope and you're
also crushing the dynamics out and
you're crushing the nuance out so
you paying you you don't get something
from nothing like you are paying for it
in one way or another and same thing
like is totally AB corollary to wine you
know the bigger the bigger the bigger
the bigger is not better and you see the
pendulum is definitely evening out I was
just up in Napa like a month ago and
tasted a lot of the 15s up there and
they're really pretty and tasted some 16
tasted some seven scenes out of barrel
and and I think that things are it's
being reeled in definitely there's
probably a whole nother podcast episode
about the relationship of aesthetics and
things happening on different levels
different scales right like I know the
human mind and I and palate apparently
are attracted to complications and all
these ways you know the simplicity gets
us first but then we want to get
something to the rabbit hole yeah
interesting yeah yeah okay so this one
let's see we this is their California
Syrah it's clearly fruitier than the
Pinot's both of them wait it's it is
it's also heavier I mean you're taking a
big step in Maadi yeah you're you're
like you're but racially or per se I
mean the the Pinot's or have a little
floral quality to yeah which I think
offsets the fruit so maybe that's it
mm-hmm
it doesn't seem especially either acidic
or tannic to me this yeah it's sellable
again I mean these are all like balanced
wines at the end of the day so that
nothing like poking out is like that's
totally what I'm going for but it's less
acidity so I would say that it is
actually pretty similar level of acidity
but okay same amount of treble but
there's more bass right there you go so
if I again you take out the trouble that
you would notice it this is same thing I
touched on with with German Riesling how
some of them can be like have sugar
levels that would shock you but you
still go and you still pucker at the end
of tasting it cuz there's acid to
balance it out right so I mean I it
almost certainly is like the pH is
probably higher than the cobs but you
know or the cob in the Brunel Clara
there's just more mmm to it all right
and the and we should yeah our final
let's go MA so this is truly one of my
favorite
that exists domain GMA karate the 2010
represent sera from the northern Rhone
so southern part france their own is
split into two parts i can't call them
halves the northern drones really only
like the top twenty percent of the
valley but these vineyards are planted
on these really steep precipitous
terraced slopes that the romans did a
lot of the terracing we've been keeping
it up since then and you have this
fairly windy place so your fair amount
south from where burgundy is what you
think it'd be warmer and it's a little
bit warmer only a couple degrees celsius
so you have wind's blowing through here
which cool down the grapes and anytime
you have water in the direct vicinity of
vineyards especially when the vineyards
around the water are on steep slopes it
acts like a solar panel so it's bouncing
sunlight back into the vineyard so you
get a level of ripeness without the heat
that you think would be necessary the
best way I've heard it explained as his
Burgundian winemaker he said that the
Sun ripens the grapes not the heat yeah
I'm just not sure if that's laying
typically I hear it but I get it it's
brought yeah getting the point across of
like you know this the things that are
making up this wine and the ripening
process it does not need to be hot nor
like really should it be and this wine
especially on the nose nothing else
smells like Jame it just has this like
peppered beef peppers that they gonna
show the Rotunda this is about with Road
smell is amazing wrote and done is a
chemical compound favorite mmm-hmm it's
floral and it is in pepper as well as in
Des Moines yeah so there's another
Oracle the other big like compound that
gets thrown around is pure zine that's
in bell peppers and jalapenos and also
in sylveon Blanc and so like you see it
often in New Zealand so be unblocked
like is notorious for you just I mean
other than smelling sometimes like cat
piss which it is famous for and not just
talking down that's well there's a
freeze the common usage is that travel
yeah
but there's a bell pepper jalapeno thing
oftentimes in that and especially you
see it there you know sodium Blanca also
makes ups on ser in France but something
about the way that Sancerre when it
grows in the soil types in the Loire
doesn't like produce it in these high
levels so you in like the sommelier
exams when you're blind tastings of
young block you just like praying for a
Marlboro New Zealand it's like nailed it
ban but yet so it's interesting because
I mean I mentioned the this strong olive
note and there's a slight olive note
here but I feel like you know it's not
overpowering in the same way I mean I'm
getting you know like a kind of a
leathery and a smoky kind of finish here
in addition to the pepper and I think it
kind of balances out the olive so it's
not as overpowering yeah I would say
like the way I would articulate that is
that you know I love favia and I meant
to stated that the Fabio Fabio quarts of
Syrah that is literally the wine that
got me into wine I had a buddy that like
convinced me to part with $40 11 years
ago that I had to think about for two
days at the time and I'm sitting
recording a podcast with you yeah a good
investment but that is the wine it
started at all and then Jim a is the
wine that got me into French wine it's
wines that are both Syrah so it's hard
for me to say so Rose not my favorite
great big eyes but there's a subjective
element here right because you know
Shawn can tell you I'm very sensitive to
things like olive there's an Amarone
that I find absolutely undrinkable
because it's like an olive punch to the
face yeah but if you balance it out it's
a wonderful note right um like you know
let's say that in the Fabia the olive is
maybe one of three or four things that
you smell and the gem a if I sit here
for ten minutes I mean there's like 10
or 12 things I could probably pull out
of this so it's in there but it's just
integrated diluted yeah integrated yeah
better word what I love about and I just
I mean other coyotes have this GMA I
think has it in spades is that it's also
floral so it sort of calls back the
Pinot's and the weight class is not much
heavier than Pinos and again I'd
mentioned it this is the lowest alcohol
this is 12/5
and you wouldn't guess No
yeah I mean I don't know I I it's funny
I don't think about it because I guess I
just the balance if you can balance wine
yeah I'm thinking about it you know I
mean I I they're all great and I don't
want to say anything against any of them
but I'm getting the feeling that the old
world wines are a teensy bit more
sophisticated and structured than the
New World wines yes more going on
perception life right um you know I so I
think about this a lot and doing what I
do and you know we're having this
conversation in 2019 right and we're
dealing with roughly two thousand year
chasm of experience difference in Europe
verse let's say California in this case
but at the same time in a way not really
like I talked about flocks or like
there's been these reset buttons that
happen and you know the first winery in
Napa
yeah first ma near in Napa I don't face
a first winter in California had to be
one of them
charles crew gets 1861 so it's a while
ago yeah it's a while ago and then you
know you have prohibition you have you
know a couple world wars to deal with
you have the depression you have these
setbacks that happen when California
wine and then not until the mid 70s with
the in the wine world infamous judgment
of Paris which I could touch on really
quick just to give some context where
there was a tasting organised in 1976
but basically the top Bordeaux producers
were sort of pitted against this
hand-picked line-up of California
Cabernet producers mainly Napa but one
from Santa Cruz Mountains and California
one now California California now what
they don't tell you is that France is
lazy at this point California is hungry
right so there's these other factors
it's not as easy as yeah you know and
and like I mentioned what the flocks are
a thing France is deep like reeling from
that dealing with that so those vines
that those wines were made from in the
the French wines and the judgment of
Paris those are all really young vines
so you've yeah there's Mouton and
there's Oprah
but it's it's in this kind of like dodgy
era of French viticulture when you have
California just trying to like just kill
it you know so that hunger factor is is
huge so I I agree with you um although I
I like it's super important to like to
not just like talk down on the new world
I'm not saying you know it is in fact I
love it and I think one of the things
that is very clear is how much fun it is
that how enlightening it is to taste
ones like this next to each other yes
that's huge that's why yeah first thing
I walked in how many wine glasses in
action because we all need to have four
turns out we have enough yeah we have
enough I'm see you can never have too
many
yeah the context is huge just being able
to go right back and forth between them
not have one and then Oh taste this okay
dump it or spit it or not or whatever
now here's another one it's not it's not
the most educational way to drink wine
and that is really what I'm passionate
about
among many parts of the wine of wine
service is that look this stuff is
really cool it's fascinating and some
people mess that up unfortunately but
like it's it's objectively there's a lot
going on and there's there is a wine out
there for everyone absolutely it was
like I I can't drink wine I don't like
wine it's like well that's that's that's
going on that is interesting I used to
be one of those people that said I just
don't like wine I was never a big
drinker and then I realized it was just
that I was drinking really bad wine yeah
it's out there you can get it oh yeah I
want to touch on this on the on the
glasses because you've picked very
different shaped glasses and people
can't see them but we have sort of
rounder more Bowl like glasses for the
Pinot's and more the classic you know
never the narrower wine glasses yeah and
and why is that and why is it important
so so the glassware things kind of
gotten crazy you know like riedle now
makes like an Oregon Pinot Noir glass a
California Pinot Noir glass a red
burgundy oh that's make weddings like I
love them all I get I want them all but
you know the the answer goes standard
answer is you know with the back to thin
skin like more let's say more delicate
styles of wine
you typically want to put in a bulb
because that bulbous shape helps contain
the aromas versus Bordeaux glass so
basically is like burgundy or Bordeaux
glass the Bordeaux glass is kind of
funnel out more powerful lines so they
kind of emphasize them more that's
roughly the way it breaks down you know
I I definitely use different kinds of
glassware you see more and more
companies just making like the one glass
I think there literally is a company
that that is the name of all wine should
go in this one and I don't necessarily
disagree with that I'm kind of somewhere
in the middle I think I could definitely
run a whole wine program on three
glasses just one like almost like a
smaller version the Bordeaux glass for
you know bright clean crisp specific
weight wines I would use this exact same
glass that we have the Pinot Noirs in
for chardonnays whether they're rich and
toasty or mineral and clean and like
more Sandra's on those bigger whites and
I also use these for champagne that's a
huge thing if I have to go pee bascinet
what's your favorite wine region
definitely it's hard not to say
champagne but this sounds like sacrilege
to put champagne in a Pinot and the
burgundy glass yes aren't you supposed
to either use the flute or the Marie
Antoinette glass yeah I vehement ly
disagree with both of the the two most
popular champagne glass choices the
flute helps you see the bubbles and
that's cool but that's what you're gonna
do yeah and then the coop I mean has the
legend it's hard to divorce from it the
coop is a great martini glass so let's
say the legend see the legend out loud
it's supposed to be based on the shape
of Marie Antoinette's breasts yes cool I
dig it I I like it as a martini glass
growing up so it's a great class yeah it
gives all the bubbles away right well so
the so let's talk about that so um the
bubbles aren't going anywhere right like
just cuz you can't see them streaming so
so champagne is a wine that is also
sparkling but it is a wine first and
foremost it's also logistically either
the hardest or maybe the second hardest
however you want to
you dry she reproduction but basically
it's a nightmare to make and you know
really like precipitous climate it's
becoming less and less so but the grapes
they use predominantly are Chardonnay
Pinot Noir and Pinot Meunier those are
the Burgundian varietals so to me
champagne goes in a burgundy glass
because I want to smell it mmm
again the nose is maybe not everything
but it's at this point for me I mean I
could just smell all these for a couple
hours and be all good and great
champagne I think a lot of champagne is
not enjoyed to the level it could be
enjoyed solely due to the glassware and
if people serve it way too cold you talk
about serving temperatures it's actually
a very good point
yeah so you know most people serve
whites too cold and reds too warm we
definitely had a lifestyle upgrade when
we got a little refrigerator for a red
watt lifestyle upgrade yeah I mean cuz
they were they're meant to be stored in
dank cold French cellar
yeah which is the average you know is
about 54 55 and we're in California yeah
right um it never gets that cold here
and so here it's so-so what it goes
along with that storage temperature and
service temperature are two different
things
storage temperature you know the caves
in Champagne and the caves in Burgundy
and the caves in Bordeaux and I'm sure
there's some difference but at the end
of the day let's call it 53 to 55 you
know typically you see lighter brighter
cleaner white wines served cooler and
then richer white wines served warmer
you know there's these like the charts
you see especially in like the sommelier
exams when you get grilled you know like
oh what's the proper serving temperature
at this point I would just fail all that
I will forgotten slash like don't care
because to me if it's balanced if it's
bright if it's complete then I can drink
it at I can drink champagne at 55 and
get way more of a nose off it and taste
it more like a wine than the people that
are drinking it when they put it in
their fridge which is legally has to
hold dairy which is 42
and so to me that's a great example of
like mastering the rules so you know how
to break them I love it
thank you Thank You Jennifer I'll take
that with me okay yeah I just I want you
to enjoy each one as as best I can and
you know temperature you can mess with
temperature and you know if there is a
like let's let's take a hot like
alcohol-wise red wine if I put it into
canner and spin an ice bucket for five
minutes and then pour it you will notice
less of yeah ethanol there's like tricks
the temperature can be used to help
wines along maybe especially from like
you know food pairing like restaurant
setting but we what's going through your
mind when you do that food pairing
restaurant setting you like so you you
are working at a restaurant like it is
you already said a sommelier should do I
think that part of the intimidation
factor with a lot of people is feeling
like they need to know which wines go
with which foods and they don't and they
don't have a vocabulary to articulate
what they want yeah so let's let's touch
on that real quick and then we'll go
right into pairing about the vocabulary
so we were talking earlier like how
should people get started and I
recommended to go to a shop get some
friends put it up talk about it learn be
honest I would say the goal is to be
able to go to a restaurant and say to a
waiter bartender sommelier whatever hi
yeah we would like a clean crisp dry
mineral driven white wine and a medium
body earth driven red wine that doesn't
have too harsh of a tannin level could
you help us with that
that is a jury you are this is humanity
is one of here yeah and it's not that
far away to be able to know like you
know that that's like maybe three trips
with a cup of friends to a wine shop you
can get at least half of each of those
sentences constructed successfully and
that comes everybody and you I mean it
will it will only help you right well
you have to figure out what you like I
mean it's just me a couple of years to
figure out that I could go into a
restaurant and say I want like a medium
to full-bodied red
not too fruity probably a little on the
older side not too young and I want like
kind of these leathery smoky long finish
kind of elements you're like 95th
percentile right there that is killing
it and I'm not an expert but I basically
said here's a vocabulary I need to learn
to communicate with my Somali eh
exactly so yet not knowing how to say it
and you know a lot of actually people
this just came to me and when you're
asking about the food and wine pairing
thing a great way to learn if you go to
a restaurant they offer a wine pairing
do the wine pairing yeah
don't make that just let someone else I
was called I don't want to think about
it option like and take an uber because
you're gonna be really plastered special
but that's okay especially if you're
coming in melis or you know if you're in
the airport go to the Vino Volo and get
a flight of different things done you
ask them totally I'd much rather have
you know three two ounce pours than one
six ounce pour so what do you look at
when you're looking at pair earrings
because that's difficult yeah that's a
whole episode but basically so I'd say
the number one thing I like to explain
to people is it the protein doesn't
necessarily drive it's oftentimes the
last thing I look at so it's not a white
wine with fish and chicken and red
language yeah so we've been taught yeah
well and that's not untrue there's just
like good exceptions to that
like the fish one like salmon is always
the blaring example I always describe
salmon it's a ribeye that swims because
it's got fat content and if it's cooked
properly it's like medium at most even
like medium-rare roll yeah there it is
okay so then we're in champagne or dry
Riesling at a bar but you know like in
and you know Pinot Noir to take a
classic a quote classic pairing that I
don't like get with only a couple
exceptions is like Pinot Noir and salmon
got really popular and it'd make like
idea reticle II I get it because you
have a lighter
usually brighter red wine with you know
this the richest of the fishes shall we
say and but he
no even when it's even when it's from
burgundy and even older there's still a
fair amount of fruit to it and yeah
fruit and fat butt heads I was thinking
an S right you want acid but I want
tannin I want to hug I want to like like
the gritty grainy like if you tasted it
on its own maybe like your saliva is
gone you're like this is dry man like I
don't know if I dig it but then and yes
the the ribeye or the ribeye of the sea
it works really well that's one example
of it you know I like I look at limiting
factors like is it spicy like for real
like actual heat the bandwidth gets
pretty narrow as to what you can use and
you want sugar to counterbalance that
you also refresh the food that way and
you know I'm for the most part of
dealing with pairings on on long the at
least four courses but sometimes seven
or ten so I'm trying to keep your palate
alive the whole time you know you're
taught that you go sparkling into light
white into rich white into light red and
medium red into heavy red and to dessert
and then you're done and I don't agree
because by the time you're 2/3 of the
way through the trajectory physically
you're tapping out you're you're I mean
I'm affecting how the food tastes it's
not just like what does the food taste
like what does the wine taste like I'm
like if you should be able to go to a
great restaurant and have a menu like
that if you don't drink alcohol and be
happy
theoretically I should be able to sit
down at a table and just have 10 wins in
a row and be happy and then when the two
come together and when the food is no
more than ever 50% of the equation and
the wine is no more ever than 50% of the
equation and everything is killing it
that's the optimal situation so you know
I'll start with you know a light whiter
or a champagne maybe just start off and
then go right into an off dry wine if
the course merits it I like going right
into a red wine at the beginning and
then right back to a white because all
the that then if I'm using acid driven
wines which I typically am that cleans
the red wine out of your palate on the
10-course menu often times at least I
look at it's like two five courses
back-to-back so I'll have champagne in
the middle
so I'm just trying to like the good
sales pitch for movies right here the
the philosophy of how to like bounce
around I mean it's not any people don't
expect it and ya know if again I don't
want to think about it option this this
I view it the stakes are high on that
you know I mean yes it's important to be
able to do the pairing thing well and so
that that's like you know how I try to
structure long menus but there's a few
things like like beef let's take beef
especially since we have two surahs' in
front of us like this is this is like
it's definitive its meaning the audit de
tousser oz what is it about the Syrah
that makes it good that like you smell
it that like every like especially the
GMA I mean there's like an animalistic
roasted thing to GMA and which you see
all the time is you know steak and
calves taking cab and that's cool but I
like kind of preach the Sirah gospel a
lot of the time with it I think that
that is a lot of times the the Sorella
seems to be comes to me as more as spicy
yeah overall typically ugly and it's
easy for it to get out of the winemakers
hands with ripeness so unbalanced yeah
yeah and then that's where wine stop
being food friendly right so like things
that are still bright and not a big
heavy cakey oily stylist raw but that
with beef is great chickens fun because
chicken is kind of like the coin flip
I literally just served white and red
side by side white burgundy red burgundy
have fun depends on you know is this
skin on is it herb they're like truffles
involved and you know we're talking
about obviously like the context of this
is I unfortunate to work in a high-end
restaurant is does not like pizza and
burgers and and either the great wines
of the world or entry level wines that
is a great support there's a really fun
thing I mean these are anything specific
I should have in mind if I know I'm
getting the nice pepperoni pizza I'm
allowed to have wine I know that I've
done it but what should I look for I
mean it's obviously sort of fatty cheesy
yeah well you know there's this there's
this kind of cheesy saying no no pun
intended with that
of you know if it grows with it goes
with it you hear so like that's why I'd
like Barolo and and like the penalty's
truffles became popular they're from the
same place so like medium body but still
bright fairly earth driven but still
fruit to glue it together that works
well with that kind of pizza good white
Burgundy and a good burger
I love I like doing I use more White's
than Reds with pairing Oh which I know
you know I can imagine a white I had not
done it but I can imagine a good white
burgundy with a burger cheeseburger
cheeseburger or not yeah there's cheese
involved a lot of people do cheese in
red and I there's only a couple times it
works to me cheese is a red it's a white
wine part of the of the meal to me and
especially some sweet wines if they're
if they are red like harder styles with
like really succulent juicy bright red
wines or fun that's also a cool
application for like the funky orange
wine thing like I mentioned yeah cheese
as a whole whole it's like we say cheese
like I mean that is like yeah yeah
exactly yeah Jesus that go beautifully
with Reds no choice yeah totally
yeah I guess I'm just I'm trying to like
refresh always I like I like when things
go up when the treble was there you know
it's interesting a couple years ago I
did a piece for Gizmodo where we did a
Girl Scout cookie and wine pairing it
they actually have worked this out I
want to do that and if it actually was a
lot of fun and educational it was
extremely educational it works less well
for Halloween candy I don't recommend it
but it has too much sugar with white
wine or a or a shrimp oh you know white
wines go very well we found with like a
shortbread or fruit we found that a very
like plummy Zinfandel went great with a
peanut butter cookie it's like eating a
peanut butter okay but the thing is the
Thin Mints those Girl Scout cookie mints
didn't go with anything they paired it
with an Amarone
which it was dreadful that olive Laden
that olive lace Amarone
very sugary almost you know it was it I
don't like a maroney's shop I'm with you
apologize I think it's a palette
difference is there wine is very
subjective and for me I Maroni it's like
a punt is that Olive punch to the face
and would combine that with a thin mint
which I normally love and it was just
like you know kung fu fighting in yes
you say that sounds like wrestling yeah
pairing shouldn't the gressil party part
of loving what you love is there
anything I mean I was gonna say Madeira
although I said with candy corn that
would probably work so like chocolate
right yeah yes a chocolate and like
specifically tawny poor or old Madeira
but the mint seems to be what makes it
hard to play I would want to pay I'd
want to play acid off mint you could do
that might be a fun I wanted can we do
this I wanted like such why were they
all just was anything sweet that you
used any dessert why they all white
drive any white wines or now there was
some white we didn't pair that we didn't
try that would be mint yeah I should
have I must think like something like a
really good pretty something Blanc could
attack that yeah good acidity
yeah if someone suggested a beer would
go well with a mint but it seems to be a
very difficult pairing and that what
struck me is very curious so yeah it's
hard like get your hands on but like old
Cabernet because there's always a minty
there could be like a eucalyptus kind of
thing going on interesting that old
Bordeaux old Bordeaux with it mean I
love it this is what I'm talking about
like it is just like that is I mean yeah
I love that if it's red and got to be
old I would say you're gonna want to eat
you fruit you need like the fruit to be
shed which I think was other than the
olive problem was probably they always
problem that like concentration and kind
of cakey almost like this gossiped
viscous nature that a lot of Amarone has
I mean there's like everyone it's like
16 and a half percent I mean that is
I don't like them yeah a lot of a huge
finger game to be honest more than you
but still not anyway there's two big
looming questions here that I had to get
to before we finish up yeah
one is you know there's a bit of mystery
not only with wine but this process of
being a sommelier being a wine expert
you can forget about the you know
certification and so forth a lot of
people like to make themselves feel
better by telling themselves that all of
wine tasting is a bit of a hoax right I
mean what in your mind goes into like
how accurate can you be identifying a
wine in a blind tasting you know how
much of it is expertise how much of its
luck how much it's reality how much of
its perception okay well so the blind
tasting in the context of wine tasting
in an exam setting would say it's
deductive what is it not what is it not
what is it not what does it not until
I've done that four times my world is
small enough to where you know I have a
pretty good idea of what's going on so
like let's take the Reds in front of us
like so again thin skin thick skin thin
skin it can only be one of so many
things so I can just before I've smelled
it like I'm walking up to the table and
sitting down I know that it's not a fair
amount of things also you're basically
saying you're looking at it and go oh
that's yeah yeah thin tend to be lighter
thick tend to be heavier like I said
there's that Grenache that can straddle
both the Zinfandel can be kind of screwy
too but and then age factors into this
but so I I haven't tested at the high
levels I don't really care to I just
sort of you have your job you have your
dream yeah I have my game and I like
French wine and I like California wine
and I just straight-up don't want to
like end up hating wine and I don't want
to like have to memorize all these
things I like really passionate about
what I do and I defend that so what I
was gonna say is that you know when
you're dealing with old wine things get
kind of screwy with the color because
red wine gets lighter and white wine
gets
darker but basically I'm sitting down
and okay thin-skinned bright like Ruby
almost magenta kind of color okay it's
almost certainly not a Syrah it's
basically anything thick-skinned I can
throw out smell it is it fruit driven is
it Earth driven these are broad strokes
but just to illustrate the process if
it's Earth driven it probably is from
the old world from Europe if it's fruit
driven it could be but it's probably not
so right there in two steps
I've yanked out a lot of things it can
be if they're white wines
I immediately taste and see if there's
residual sugar because if there is then
my world about really smell or smell and
hope it's that Marlboro soft Blanc but
and you know that to go back to what I
was talking about what the acid level
the tannin level the balance between the
fruit and the earth flavors I mean you
can triangulate a lot of things through
that and they're not trying to screw
with you they're not trying to like
they're not gonna serve you Santa
Barbara County Tempranillo like they're
serving you classic examples yeah
let me test your actual knowledge not
yeah yeah it is hard because you know
like you asked about like the you
mentioned vintage like that that's you
know oh is it 78 is it 61 you know that
is part rote memorization of like
classic vintages and just how vintage is
function in different regions and that
that's definitely there's a learning
curve to that and it's really hard to
taste those one you have to either have
a trust fund or you have to I do we know
expert on super expensive for work well
but not even just expensive but like
getting your hands on old wines that
have been stored well they're gonna show
like they should show like which they
tend to go up in price but I'm not even
talking about the astronomical stuff
it's just it's a hard thing to come
across and a hard thing to have a
extensive mental rolodex to be able to
dial through and go okay I think it's I
think it's 30 40 years old I think it's
Bordeaux okay so what's 70 I got you
know 75 that's classic it's showing more
tertiary flavors than something like a
ripe 82 would I don't think it's 82
could be 86 weird funky you know you're
going like
like you're jumping through the hurdles
but you know if you with the deductive
process you can get pretty close and you
know you got to show your work right
it's it you can't just like show up and
like I drink you know I'm killing it I
had this last night it's you 1990
demands a makeover t-bone why you know a
lot long division so and it is useful
it's humbling oh my god it's real I mean
yeah it is yeah of course I mean people
who are good at it people who are not
good yeah and so what I love so this
makes me think of I get this a lot at
the restaurant like oh you must have a
great palette to do what you do it's
like well I can I I think I have my mind
I split hair as well right so and it's
like the palette like if you do it
enough there's a scene in the psalm
documentary where they tied the best way
to describe it no one's a natural board
samurai sword maker but like you had a
teacher that had a teacher that a
teacher and if you taste 2025 wines at
night five days a week for even a month
much less a couple years and you're
paying attention at all your palate will
exponentially quote improve you just
have more things to play off right you
know Sean mentioned the this sort of
backlash against wine that it's all BS
that you know there really is no
difference and there's a famous example
where you know people like to cite that
a you know Somali A's were blindfolded
and couldn't tell the difference between
red white and white wine and that always
bothered me because to me the sensory
experience of wine is not just the taste
or rather taste is smell its vision its
everything that goes on with it it's a
much more complicated thing and the
minute you blindfold somebody you're
tying both their hands behind their back
yeah I mean I just think like okay what
are you going to do a like what what
happened to you
[Laughter]
and I mean how people take this way too
seriously
yeah supposed to be having fun
especially
fine let's not forget I mean it is a
fascinating subject matter no one ever
is going to know everything about it
it's it's the chasing the horizon of you
know kind of learn have this perspective
on it
and it's people screwed up yeah people
don't know that or insecure about it and
wanted
I mean having said that okay let's be
fair it makes we've been in restaurants
where there have been better and worse
sommelier to alright and that's partly
inability to distinguish wines but it's
also a sort of a human interaction like
what do they want
it is hospitality yeah before it's
anything else and it's entertainment
especially that when you're you know
actually not even I was gonna say at the
level of you know these Michelin star
fancy restaurant no it's I resented that
at every level it is entertainment and
going out to dinner should be fun and if
you are privileged enough to get to say
that you make your money from being a
sommelier you there is a like
ideological philosophical weight on your
shoulders to not be a douche bag please
write please it's just probably in
completely satisfied by the set of
sommelier is in the world I mean I
always taste
I think the psalm documentaries have
done a lot to help it good I always say
like being a cosmologists should make
you humble
yes compared to the universe you're very
small and yet there are plenty of
colleges right yeah fulfilled this yeah
but like let's figure out how like what
we how little we know yeah that's right
that is the like at the end of the day
you know there'll be a last time you
taste wine and like it's not something
that is this competitive thing is this
lord it over people like culture that I
unfortunately see just from you know
clientele or not even quite from
Sommeliers you know like oh I'm drinking
this I'm drinking that it's like cool
didn't be humble right then you're
privileged right in
you know a lot of us get to drink wines
like kings of countries are never gonna
taste so it's like cool quick fortune
enough to chew or to choose his path and
fortunate to get to pull it off you have
to wield that with with humility and and
and empathy for you it is not your
dinner yeah it is your to dinner
absolutely yes dinner it is not like
what do you want if you want Barolo and
oysters like let's do it I did if that's
what if you were in Piemonte a and you
had a disparate it lit your whole world
on fire and you were eating oysters and
you want to recreate that and I'm just
going like whoa that is no nothing is
gonna work about that everything works
about that if you're sitting there with
your like all the systems go everything
firing like this is about having fun and
let's not forget like you're consuming
alcohol like why are you becoming more
of a douche it's everything is
everything is all good right except that
the world is falling apart so the final
issues I want to talk about is the idea
that you know our climate is changing
wine is already indirectly it upon the
fact that it is it is changing this is
not up for debate here in mindscape
how does it affect it I can see at least
two possibilities if there is an effect
which I'm sure there is one would be
like wine throughout the world gets
worse because we're growing it in
climates that we're not used to but then
there's the more optimistic possibility
that you know wine just changes we make
champagne in Britain rather than in
champagne sparkling wine sparkling wine
yes but yeah the one will change but be
just as good I don't know how for the
optimistic or pessimistic here um well I
I mean I don't after having said what I
just said I think I have no choice but
to be optimistic about it and I don't
know what the point would be I mean it's
good it is changing it's already changed
I've been in involved in wine and
interested in wine loving wine for
eleven years and even in that amount of
time it's changed you know looking at
like we talked about alcohol levels and
regions like they are going up and it's
not just due to like the critic thing
like I mentioned it's part of it but
like just
things are heating up and vintages
especially in the kind of marginal
places become more erratic like you see
that in Burgundy you see more hail and
like spring and in the summer what they
deal with a fair amount but that reduces
the yields so there's less wine that's a
whole other thing that doesn't get
talked about a lot with what climate
change is gonna do you know obviously
everything's heating up ripeness levels
are gonna go up but each vineyard like
there needs to be vintages that let the
vineyards like reset like in times I was
at this producer in in Volney in
burgundy the Marquis Dondre ville this
amazing winery and the proprietor was
talking about how what they're situated
in this specific place in Volney where
they're these basically valleys cut into
the hill that makes up burgundy called
combs and winds come through there and
cool down the vineyards on the edges but
then also bring in storms and you said
there's a lot of cyclical storms late
they know if they'll get hit one year at
one time they're like oh okay so the
next two that we know so that's
happening more yields going down while
things are getting riper so that right
there just the street math of that I
think about because you know I've been
mentioning how like wine ages and older
mines are beautiful well okay so there's
obviously time is ticking the arrow of
time someone I know said you know the
wise are being made now are going to
take you know let's say these the top
top-level Burgundy's and Bordeaux's and
for like 2015 vintage those are at least
20 probably 30 40 plus year wines before
they're really firing on all cylinders
mm-hmm and those are being made in a
time where we know more about
viticulture than we ever have and
there's less of them and because they're
riper they're more accessible young so
people get trigger-happy so like the
allocations that used to be cases are
now bottles and people are popping them
so when you extrapolate this out the
amount of people that are really going
to know
what 2015 you know richebourg is
drinking like is smaller and then you
combine that with the way the markets
have gone crazy the prices have just
gone through the roof like it's this
like unsustainable and in certain
regions I mean like there I don't know
there's a correction that's gonna happen
or just things are like David talks
about how these the marginal places and
I've been to marginal places but what
are now like in the Goldilocks zone you
fast forward the clock the grape makeup
might have to be replanted like dis like
sacrilegious sentence of like so like is
Pinot Noir really what should be in
Burgundy in 15 years like it Scott like
are the wine makers really facing up to
this you think well you're also doing
with they're really in places in certain
times certain people like I'd kind of
dogmatic way yeah it's a traditional is
like you pay your fee in wine world
works but um yeah there's a couple like
avant garde people like they're
experimenting with Syrah and burgundy
and you know things like the Willamette
Valley in Oregon it will be good for a
minute but then like maybe some Syrah
there wouldn't be a bad thing but then
you look at like Napa like you're
already a cab you know like where do you
go where you go there's what or two
sometimes a cab just it's just that
really hot on Cabernet Sauvignon sorry
the Kemeny yeah oh yeah it handles warm
climates well yeah that's what I'm
pretty good at here yeah it's it's a
resilient grape can handle a lot the way
the canopies are trimmed is another
thing I've heard people talk about where
you know depending on which way like if
you're in the northern hemisphere for
example the vineyard faces south you get
better exposure than it to the Sun and
the vineyard faces north
so it'd be planting North facing
vineyards and not trimming the canopy as
much so that you have more cover things
like that but that's that's a band-aid
if you're really looking at this macro
view another thing that no one knows
what's you know how to deal with it all
the way there's these you know
experiments going on but
it it's already much different than it
was if you even just take the 21st
century it sounds like you know people
are doing things there's reasons to
think that there will be changes but not
you know the end of the world kind of
changes yet it'll be nicer if we did not
destroy the planet yeah no it's true and
you know the reality that I figure with
the exact exact stat is but like you
know just take like gasoline cars for
example you just snap your fingers and
you know no more made and everyone's
electric you're still 25 30 years out
before those are in the junkyard like
you know it is like trains obviously
left the station so I think that's you
know it's not as simple as like oh so we
like pick earlier well you also have to
physiologically ripen the grid like
ditch and bandit like it won't it's not
sustainable
yeah it's it's you already see it at the
main way I see it is in the production
which is ironic because you're like oh
it's getting warmer like the yields can
be higher but not necessarily especially
since I'm dealing with mainly European
wines the erratic nature of the of the
vintages is the is the kicker I mean
it's a it's a I always like to end the
podcast on optimistic note but I mean I
think I will make a slight exception
here we said plenty of optimism there is
plenty of optimism but also you know we
have to face up to the reality that this
is part of the the complexity and joy
and and pleasure of wine compared to
other things is the ancientness of it
the tradition of it the fact that so
much knowledge is just empirical we're
not exactly sure why we can't point to
the right chemical compounds and say
this is what makes it good but we know
that growing it and making this way
makes it good and that's changing and
that's kind of a shame we're doing
everything people people are doing
things to make it better but there's a
possibility something will be lost and
so again more reason to enjoy it well we
have yeah definitely well and you know I
mean something something will be lost
but you know again like being optimistic
we know more now then
we did when these storied vintage
legendary wines were made so the best
wines being made or being made now
yeah we're drinking better Wiley the
Thomas Jefferson ever could a minute yes
yes totally and that's not stopping that
so there is adaptation there's evolution
that I mean will happen you know like by
choice or not basically and yeah we got
a I mean also Thomas Jefferson never
appeared on a podcast once that so it's
true too bad for him really yeah alright
nothing to see thanks so much for being
here thanks for bringing the wise Thank
You Jennifer Willett for joining us
cheers Cheers
this is a great experience uh looking
forward to my next trip to melis all
about it I love it Thanks
[Music]
you
[Music]